En muchos videos hemos hablado de metales
y enlaces metálicos, y en este video vamos
a profundizar un poco más sobre esto, en
particular vamos a hablar sobre aleaciones,
que son mezclas de elementos que aún conservan
propiedades metálicas. Entonces, ¿cuáles son
algunas propiedades metálicas? Bueno, tienden
a ser brillantes, reflejan la luz. Esta es una
muestra de hierro puro; podemos ver que refleja
la luz. Tienden a ser maleables, lo que significa
que podemos doblarlo sin romperlo, y tienden a
conducir electricidad. En una aleación, al mezclar
varios elementos, aún se conservan la mayoría
de estas propiedades. Y sólo como un repaso,
¿de dónde provienen estas propiedades? Podemos
imaginar los enlaces metálicos. Tenemos un video
completo sobre esto. Digamos que tomamos un montón
de hierro. Se puede ver aquí: hierro, es un metal
de transición, y lo que sucede con los metales es
que cuando forman enlaces entre sí los átomos no
son tan electronegativos, no quieren acaparar los
electrones, no los quieren sólo para ellos, por
lo que están dispuestos a compartir sus electrones
de valencia en una especie de piscina comunitaria
de electrones. Y a pesar de que tenemos un montón
de átomos de hierro neutro, en realidad podríamos
verlo como iones cargados positivamente en un
mar de electrones. Y entonces tenemos un montón
de electrones aquí. ¿Y de dónde vienen estos
electrones? Bueno, estos son los electrones de
valencia de los átomos neutros que contribuyen
a esta piscina, y es por eso que la mayoría de
los metales son buenos para conducir electricidad,
por eso son maleables. Y, dependiendo del metal,
si estamos hablando de un metal del grupo 1,
podríamos imaginar que la carga de estos iones
aquí sería +1, pero si estamos hablando de un
metal del grupo 2 o un metal de transición tienen
más electrones de valencia con los que podrían
contribuir a este grupo, e incluso pueden tener
una carga positiva de 2 o una carga positiva de
3. Pero como se prometió al principio, hablaremos
sobre la noción de aleaciones. Y vamos a hacer
estos diagramas de partículas que hemos visto en
otros videos. Y en los diagramas de partículas no
vamos a mostrar esta piscina de electrones, pero
nos ayudarán a visualizar la estructura de las
aleaciones. Así que imaginemos cómo podría ser el
hierro. Y sólo vamos a ver un corte bidimensional
de un sólido de hierro, donde todos los átomos de
hierro han formado enlaces metálicos. Y como dije,
no vamos a dibujar esta piscina de electrones,
pero podrían formar una estructura bastante
regular, algo como esto. Y cada uno de estos
círculos representa un átomo de hierro, pero como
les prometí, este video trata sobre aleaciones,
así que imaginemos cómo se vería el acero. Esta es
una cuchilla de acero, y el acero es un montón de
hierro, por lo que una vez más podemos visualizar
cada uno de estos como un átomo de hierro, pero
mezclado con ese hierro hay un poco de carbono. Y
cuando vemos la tabla periódica de los elementos,
podemos ver que el carbono está bastante más
arriba en la tabla periódica y a la derecha
del hierro. El hierro neutro tiene 26 protones
y 26 electrones y el carbono neutro sólo tiene
6 protones y 6 electrones. Los electrones de
valencia en el carbono están en su segundo nivel,
los electrones de valencia del hierro están en el
cuarto nivel, entonces el carbono es un poco más
pequeño, y así, cuando mezclamos ese carbono, al
ser más pequeño, cabe en los espacios entre los
hierros, por lo que es posible que tengamos...
Dibujaré esto aquí. Es posible que tengamos un
poco de carbono ahí, es posible que tengamos un
poco de carbono acá, es posible que tengamos un
poco de carbono allá, entonces, cuando se forma
una aleación donde un átomo tiene un radio
mayor o un radio significativamente mayor que el
otro, se forman cosas como esta, que se conocen
como aleaciones intersticiales. Y el acero de
carbono es un buen ejemplo de ello. Tenemos otras
situaciones en las que hay aleaciones entre átomos
de tamaño similar. Y esto justo aquí es latón. No
sé si es un reloj o un astrolabio o algo así,
pero el latón está hecho de una mezcla de cobre
y zinc. Entonces, cuando tenemos una aleación
como ésta, de átomos con radio similar, se llama
una aleación sustitucional. Podemos imaginar que
parte del cobre ha sido sustituido por zinc, esta
es una aleación sustitucional. Ahora, quizás se
estén preguntando si puede haber una combinación
de ambos, y, de hecho, sí se puede. Esto de aquí
son paneles en la Estación Espacial Internacional,
y están hechos de acero inoxidable. Es probable
que tengan acero inoxidable en su cocina,
y podríamos ver el acero inoxidable como acero
básico, pero en lugar de sólo hierro y carbono
también hay un poco de cromo mezclado.
Y para que podamos visualizar esto,
si se trata de acero inoxidable tal vez los azules
son de hierro, pero tenemos un poco de cromo. Lo
dibujaré con rojo. El cromo tiene un radio similar
al del hierro, no es exactamente igual pero está
cerca. Tenemos un poco de cromo aquí, un poco
de cromo justo por acá y si fuera sólo cromo y
hierro lo llamaríamos sustitucional, pero también
tenemos carbono, y el carbono tiene un radio más
pequeño. Así que dibujamos un poco de carbono
en los espacios entre los átomos más grandes:
un poco de carbono ahí, un poco de carbono por
aquí. Este es un ejemplo de una aleación que
es tanto intersticial como sustitucional. Ahora,
una última pregunta: todo esto es interesante pero
¿por qué hemos decidido poner cosas como carbono
en el hierro? Bueno, resulta que poniendo un
poco de carbono o mezclándolo con otros metales
podemos cambiar las propiedades y, por ejemplo,
el acero como aleación es mucho más fuerte que
el hierro por sí solo, y el acero inoxidable,
una vez que se mezcla ese cromo, es mucho
más resistente a la corrosión que el acero
básico. Con esto terminamos por hoy. Acabamos de
aprender un poco más sobre metales y aleaciones.